so if some of the encounters are
actually representing
alien civilizations visiting us
why do you think
they're doing so
you suggested that perhaps it's this
study understand their own past
right right what what what are some of
the motivations do you think and
again from from our perspective us as
humans what motivations would we have
when we approach other civilizations we
might discover in the future
well i think one motivation might be to
steer us away from the precipice
right or on the assumption that you know
even if we make it past the precipice at
least
uh we're not a bunch of psychopaths you
know running around so maybe there's a
little bit of motivation there to make
sure that your the neighbor that's
growing up next to you is not
you know unruly
um you know but i mean maybe it's sort
of a moral imperative
like what we have with you know creating
uh
national parks where animals can
continue to
live out their lives in a natural way
i don't know i mean that would be
i mean the problem is we're imagining
from a
anthropomorphic
viewpoint what an alien might think and
as i've said before
alien means alien right i mean not
hollywood aliens
but
a whole different way of thinking
and a whole different level of
experience and let's say wisdom
hopefully
that we could only hope to understand
you